later today washington d.c catholic
archbishop wilton gregory is scheduled
to be
elevated to cardinal cardinals are the
highest ranking officials of the church
after the pope chris livesay is at the
vatican this morning where the
coronavirus is overshadowing what is
otherwise a crowded
joyous ceremony chris good morning
good morning wilton gregory is about to
receive his cardinals red hat a first
for a black american and also for the
first time coveted restrictions amid a
consistory now gregory is in protective
isolation until the big ceremony
but he spoke to us from inside the
vatican
the naming of cardinals the new princes
of the church comes with all the pomp
you'd expect from 2 000 years of
tradition
that is any other year than 2020. how
difficult is that for you to have to
maintain a distance from the very people
you need to minister to
chris it's one of the most painful
experiences of
any minister especially for one whose
ministry is marked by welcoming people
namely those from diverse walks of life
from the lgbtq
plus community to african americans if
you've heard of gregory the archbishop
of washington d.c
it might have been this summer as black
lives matter protesters marched through
the capitol
and were violently forced away so
president trump
bible in hand could pose in front of
saint john's episcopal church
the next day when the president visited
the saint john paul
ii national shrine gregory called it
baffling
and reprehensible he hopes his
relationship with president-elect joe
biden
will be different so that you don't
begin
with condemnation you begin with
conversation
and like biden gregory has experience
with entering an office
at a time of crisis last year pope
francis named him archbishop of
washington dc
the same year francis defrocked one of
his predecessors
theodore mccarrick for sex abuse
culminating this month
in a groundbreaking vatican report let's
be honest chris
it revealed some awful uh
events and huge mistakes
on the part of church leadership
and the sex abuse crisis is far from
over gregory says church leaders need to
be held more accountable
just as he becomes even more of a leader
than before
for cbs this morning saturday chris
lives say rome